Hello Freak bitches.
And that's the problem with that,
with a lot of what's happening in our
government. People saying, you know what,
I really want to believe in this absurd
story and therefore I refuse to accept
evolution. If you're the vibe, if you're
Mike Pence, the vice president of country,
you say,
I don't believe evolution because I don't,
it doesn't agree with my
ridiculous fundamentalist ideas.
And he said that in
Congress, right? He said,
we shouldn't be teaching
evolution in schools.
We should be teaching intelligent
design. And, and why? Because he, he, it,
it offends his personal faith.
Perhaps it might also be a political
ploy. It might be. I think he's,
he knows that a large percentage of the
country finds comfort in a leader that
subscribes to the same sort of
superstitions that they did. Yeah.
Yeah. I, I, that could be a, he did this
before. He was in a national officer.
He was a congressman. I suspect he
did it. It sounds like he believed it,
but you're right. Who knows. Right. But,
but the point is that we, we, we
should realize that the only, that,
that we shouldn't listen to that kind
of nonsense because we may not want,
because there are a lot of people in
this country who do think that evolution
directly confronts their belief in God
or the Big Bang directly confronts their
belief in God and therefore they don't
want their children to learn about that.
But what an awful thing to do to your
children to withhold evidence about how
the world really works.
Because you don't,
you don't have to believe in the big bang,
but it really happened.
You don't have to believe in evolution.
But it happened.
It's like Philip k Dick said the,
the,
the science fiction writer reality
is that which continues to exist,
whether or not you believe in it.
Okay.
And so you may not want to believe
in it, but it happened. And,
and for you to withhold that kind of
knowledge from your kids because you're
worried it's going to affect
their faith is, in my opinion,
child abuse because you're hindering their
capabilities as an adult in a society
which is highly technological
to function effectively.
They're doing it because they believe
in as well when they need. It's right.
I'm not believing they think they're
helping their kids, but most of,
I don't know if you're a
parent. I am. We've all screwed
up our kids, right? Yeah.
We all do things for our kids because
we think it's good for them and,
and sometimes it is
and sometimes it isn't.
I'm not saying these people
are doing it because they,
they want to hurt their children.
They think somehow that not believing
in God makes you a bad person. Right.
But there's no evidence
of that. In fact, in fact,
a Steve Weinberg who a Nobel prize winning
physicist has said, and I love it, he,
he, he said, so they're good people
in the world. They're bad people,
good people to good things,
bad people do bad things.
When good people do bad things,
it's religion.
Do you think that religion in its earliest
stages was in a sense primitive man
with no science trying to figure out the
world and trying to have some sort of
rules like almost like a
scaffolding in order to,
to move to the next. If you see that it
exists in so many different cultures,
it might have been something along that
was that way.
It their effort.
It was their effort to understand the
world around them based on what they knew
it was noble.
You know,
they tried to understand the world
and so there's nothing wrong with it.
But claiming that we today should
be guided by the worldview of,
of illiterate peasants in the Iron Age.
Peasants who, who didn't know the earth,
orbiting the sun and wrote down scriptures
based on their beliefs at the time.
They'll argue that that
should guide our life.
Today when we discovered a hundred
billion galaxies in the universe and
discovered all this stuff is ludicrous.
So you're absolutely,
the birth of science and religion
are the same. And in fact,
modern science grew out of religion.
People point that out and they say to me,
how dare you talk about religion?
You know, as, as being outdated.
Science grew out of religion. And
I say to them, well that's fine,
but children outgrow their
parents, right? So great.
No doubt,
religious ideas and all early scientists
were religious because it was the only
game in town.
You couldn't be educated except the
church controlled all the universities.
And so it was like the National
Science Foundation of the 16th century.
It's not surprising they were
all religious because that's,
that was the only game in town.
So that,
that co helped create the
birth of modern science.
But science outgrew it and that's okay.
Kids outgrow their parents.
Thank goodness.
Well,
I think maybe that might help
kids outgrow their parents.
Why the getting religion forced down
your throat is one of the best ways for
kids to, for some kids as they get older.
Some for some kids it's like you and me,
but I get lots of letters.
You know,
we made this movie called the unbelievers
and, and about, which followed me,
Richard Dawkins and I around the
world as we talked about this stuff.
And it was nice and maybe, and I, and I
hope, and it's a, it's a well made film.
I liked the moat filmmakers made it,
but I found people come up to me.
I had no idea of this.
It's one of the negative aspects of
religion that I never appreciated.
I have people come up and he almost
everyday or write me and saying,
you know what?
I saw that movie and I realized I'm not
a bad person for asking questions and
I'm not alone. You know, these
people from small towns in Georgia,
they have no one to talk to.
They think that the only ones who's
asked the question, is God real?
Is it okay to not believe in God?
And they're told by everyone else
he'll not only you'll go to hell,
but you're a bad person and suddenly
they discover that's not true.
And so I think there are a lot of people
who have that forced down their throats.
It's really hard when you're a
kid, you know, and have these.
And that's why I do think any kind of
religion for kids is kind of child abuse
not.
And no matter what,
because these concepts of a dainty and
the possible existence of a purpose of
university are very deep and
subtle concepts and expect
a three year old kid to,
to,
to Ram that down at cure all kids' throat
is unfair because the kid rested it.
It ends up being internalized in
ways. And a lot of people, you know,
I hear a lot of people who've had deep
religious educations who say, you know,
it's hard to outgrow that
because when you get,
when that's rust into you as a child,
it's really hard to over ever overcome it.
The guilt feelings that many religions
introduce the fundamental notion that,
that you know,
you're ultimately sinful and no
matter what you do is sinful,
is something a lot of
people have hard times with.
And that claim of sin is just so you know,
I've debated people who you know,
who argue that homosexuality
is, is, is, is sinful, you know,
and then, and it's unnatural.
God intended it to be otherwise.
And then I pointed out,
well, you know what?
You take all mammals 10% in every species,
almost 10% have homosexual relationships.
Sheep have long 10% of sheep of
longterm homosexual relationships,
or they sinful. Okay?
It's not a natural at all.
It's a natural consequence of
whatever by now why it's a case.
It's an interesting evolution of question,
but it's certainly not a
natural and seems uniform.
Then if it's 10% plus or minus a little
bit, it certainly seems to be biology.
There's some purpose. There's some,
there's some biological purpose to it.
And so to argue that it's both unnatural
and wrong is to misunderstand biology.
But people grow up being told it's
evil because the Bible said it.
And then they don't want to give people
who homosexual the same rights as other
people because they tell them,
they say God didn't want
them to have the homestead.
So the problem is people are told these
things that are ultimately wrong because
you know, maybe, you know,
because for whatever reason,
the tribe that wrote down that that
scripture wanted to make sure that the,
there weren't homosexual
relationships in the group,
which is really baffling when you talk
to people about the Bible in the Old
Testament versus the new testament.
And they don't even understand where
the new testament was created by
Constantine and a bunch of bishops. They
threw a bunch of stuff. And by the way,
they think it's kindler gentler. Sure.
The Old Testament is one of the most,
you know, look at the current people
say the Qur'an is violent and vicious.
Read the Old Testament.
You know,
you're supposed to stone your
kids if they disobey you.
And the reason kill people that were
two different types of cloths. Exactly.
And the reason that nowadays sort of the
old Abrahamic religions of Judaism and
Christianity may seem a little less
violent than Islam for some people,
is because, you know, people
take the Quran literally,
and that's part of sort of
fundamentalist Islam. Very few,
very few people take the Bible
as literally as it namely, Hey,
we're going to stone kids in
the 12th century. They may have,
but now we've outgrown it. And the
Islam is 600 years younger. And so it's,
it's just the old testament is
just as violent as the Qur'an,
but no one takes it seriously.
But people,
most people who call themselves religious,
they pick and choose the things they like
from the Bible or the New Testament or
the old testament. They pick and choose
the nice kinder, gentler things. You know,
Richard Dawkins Foundation in England
did an interesting survey. Uh, so they,
the British government does a
census, you know, and, and they,
they ask people's religions as part of it.
And in the last census,
remarkably only 55% of the people
said they were Christian Church,
Church of England, which was one
of the lowest ever. But fine,
they went to those 55% people. They did
a survey of those and they said, okay,
why do you call yourself Christian?
Do you believe in the Virgin birth?
Do you believe in transubstantiation?
Do believe in, you know,
and went down the list and people say,
no, no, no, no, no. And then they'd ask,
why do you call yourself Christian?
And the answer was,
we like to think of ourselves as good
people. So religion is USERP morality.
And somehow people throw
out all of the evil.
And it's not just the Old Testament.
No one talked about hell
more than Jesus Christ. Okay?
Jesus guy is supposed to love.
Everyone talked about hell.
This eternal damnation for
people who disobey as, as,
as Christopher Hitchens used to say,
God is like a cosmic Saddam Hussein,
but worse cause it almost saying use
just torture his enemies while they're
alive. God has worse. He takes
the people that I was like,
it torches them from all eternity.
Who wants such a God? What an awful,
disgusting idea.
Okay.